the Clippers are now 13 and five two and
a half games behind the 15 and two
Lakers in the Western Conference to talk
about that and everything else going on
in this world of sports in Los Angeles
that has a no doubt national interest
the column is from the Los Angeles Times
Arash marcozzi good to see you sir
thanks for having me I must say this
because this is what I have learned in
living here since 2003 to another los
Angelino on a rainy day thanks for going
outside yeah I walk across the street
but I drove across listen we have a
weird parking situation at the Times
right now and where it's it's it's a far
Drive by Los Angeles State can we figure
out would you mind right now how far it
is it has to be it has to be less than a
tenth of a mile right oh I don't want to
be drenched I understand you do have
situations very VIP spot as the crow
flies 500 feet it's not from where my
car was parked yeah my driving is 0.3
miles the way you circle around the
parking lot to find the best parking
spot and you know honestly it's just you
know my wife's from the New England area
I'm from New York and we have since
moving out here it's just like do you
want to go out tonight it's raining we
really like you know what we'd rather
just stay inside and it's it's not like
it's 20 degrees outside it's not like a
blizzard yeah it's just it's raining and
you know and then when the Lakers are
the Clippers play on a night when it's
raining the first quarter tip-off
Laurent there they're not there yet it
takes forever because people don't know
how to drive in the rain here in Los
Angles
with all due respect
and at any rate thanks for making it
here was fine for you drive back will be
fun to know a when it's like the first
rain big rain and it's just like yeah
but the wipers are really checked on it
well okay now here's the transitions you
guys have judged me if I ask for a car
service from the top the Lakers every
single I've never seen a team go from
nationally considered what would you say
June dumpster fire yeah to November
champion quite like a Lakers team I mean
this is amazing how this is all worked
out so far cuz there's not even that the
kid Nevel stuff that's going exactly
Taco Tuesday jokingly but I just love
how together this team is and I found
that out in training camp and and the
preseason and you don't want to put too
much pressure or too much you know like
it's just the preseason but they enjoy
playing together and so it was very
combustible coaching staff combustible
team it's been amazing so far they've
been the best team in the league and
they enjoy playing together mm-hmm and
and LeBron and Anthony Davis have been
terrific
I mean opening night was basically the
only I I know they've lost twice but
opening night against the Clippers team
is really they've they haven't looked
back yes since that at this point
caution people because I said the best
team in the league when they're healthy
is the Clippers and we're seeing that
right now and here's the thing rich
defensively is what makes that team so
unique and they were good before with
Chris Paul and Blake Griffin but they
didn't have that championship chemistry
they didn't really like each other they
they were a good team I think they were
a top five top four team this Clippers
team when they're healthy they just have
something about them we're like they
want to stop you they want to score but
they also don't want you to score that
the maze
two-way players so the top two teams in
the NBA I think are right here in Los
Angeles I think so I mean Denver is 13
and 3 technically right in between them
Rockets Mavericks Jazz are pretty much
the ones that are closest to them in the
standings
so um Anthony Davis same what he said in
Chicago that surprised by that what was
that about what he said it was just for
those who you know he basically said at
a at a Q&A with a bunch of kids hey this
is my hometown and
you know next year it's probably he
threw it out there that his free agency
stay tuned next year's like that so it's
just like that is a possibility I don't
know why he would say that I I don't
think he's gonna leave I think he loves
Chicago so I think maybe in that moment
in time he wanted to say listen I love
Chicago I'm from here you don't know
what's gonna happen but why even put
that out there that was really the only
controversy we've had from this team
through the first month or so of the
season and it wasn't really that big of
a controversy and interestingly enough
tonight people will be surprised there's
a lot of Laker fans in Louisiana so I
know there's gonna be a lot of people
expecting them to boo him and they will
boo him but it won't be as bad as people
think I don't think one and half their
team from last year's on the floor there
Lonzo ball it looks like is gonna play
tonight and so David's returning there
they will boo the heck out of it they
won't move him but I don't think it'll
be like a lot I think people have come
kind of compared it like LeBron going
back to Cleveland or KD going back to
the Thunder either they're gonna boo him
mm-hmm but I don't think it's gonna be
as terrible as people think
Josh mikaze the Los Angeles Times sports
columnist kind enough to get in his car
and drive farther to be here on the Rich
Eisen show I'm sorry I mandated to reset
my my my my my apologies I do appreciate
you being here so before we move on to
the Los Angeles football teams can you
explain to me what the NBA is actually
considering about their regular season
schedule and their playoff schedule
because I didn't understand what woods
and Zach Lowe put out there what they're
considering and Daryl Morey we talked
about it on Twitter I said I think I
need your MIT degree to understand you
so it's a little you know if you're a
soccer fan if you're a European soccer
fan you get it where there's like the
Champions League and there's also like
the league championship so they want to
have this tournament where if you're a
novice fan this time of year where you
don't normally care about the league
until the end of the suits until the
Superbowl this will give you a reason to
care I just don't know how significant a
midseason tournament will will be like
if you're the Chicago Bulls and you've
won the mid-season Tournament what's the
significance of that in European soccer
there's significance to the Champions
League in these tournaments I I don't
love it but I see what they're trying to
do they're trying to for fans who don't
normally care about the league until
January here's a reason for you to care
I don't underst I don't understand I
still don't understand it so there's
there would be 78 regular season games
but the tournament wouldn't count as the
regular season games or they would and
then if if we're load managing stars
because we're load managing stars in
November and December because they know
how long of a grind it is to make sure
that they're healthy in April and May
and June yeah why would stars not be
load managed during a tournament yeah
and what would there be a bonus would
there be a bonus okay
it would be a trophy for this midseason
tournament but the issue rich is like
who's gonna care about this midseason
tournament in year one it's just like
it's just a new thing that they've
created so it doesn't really mean
anything to the fans I don't think yet
listen I get why they're trying to give
some significance to games in November
in December but I don't know if there's
a good way well I mean it correct me if
I'm wrong and I might be wrong and it
might cause soccer fans to be yelling at
their radio or their television sets but
the Champions League is called the
Champions League for a reason yeah those
are the best so you know you can't throw
the five and eleven Grizzlies and a
chance tournament right so wouldn't you
be taking only the best of the best like
maybe last year's top yes
14
be good but wouldn't that disadvantage
to the rest of the leg that they're
chilling out or they're playing regular
season games while these guys from last
year are doing battle but then the
Lakers wouldn't be involved because they
would be and then would there be
relegation you know me like I read this
thing over and over again and still
didn't understand it well enough to
explain wait great questions and I don't
have all the answers and I don't even
think the league does yet just trying to
find a sweet spot for it how do we make
these games significant because the
season for so many fans begins on
Christmas yes listen if you're a
football fan you're not really paying a
lot of attention right now unless you're
like a Lakers fan or a Clippers fan and
your team is good but again I get why
the league is having these conversations
I don't know if there's like a sweet
spot there where it can work
arash mark Ozzie here on the Rich Eisen
show is there a Chargers problem here in
this town there is a Chargers problem
but I don't think it's all by going to
London I think listen I was part of this
generation of fans that the league
ignored during this 21 years they did
not have a single preseason game here
they didn't have training camp here they
didn't do a thing here and the Chargers
and the Rams come back into town and
they expect us to be hardcore fans like
there's no hardcore fans now there may
be Rams fans who stayed as Rams fans and
they're hardcore fans or there may be
Chargers fans who are from San Diego and
now make that trip up but day one Los
Angeles Rams fans day one Chargers fans
that hardcore that's developed over time
that does not I mean it does not you
don't have that here now it can work but
it takes time now the issue with the
Chargers if they needed to rebrand just
the name Los Angeles charger sounds
weird and it will sound weird for a long
time so I don't know if there's a
there's a pathway to success for the
Rams I don't think there's a pathway
towards success for the Los Angeles
chargers and then as we wrap up our
conversation here on the college
football playoff rankings there's a top
25 yeah people don't usually get further
than number six when you're talking
about playoff ranking but number 22 is
USC Southern California sitting there is
is clay Helton saving his job what's
going on with the there's so much going
on
in management there and obviously with
the top of the school and so much going
on with the change in athletic
department is clay Helton still maybe
gonna be the coach does have a chance to
keep his job because I think he hasn't
done a terrible job but by USC standards
if your standard is a playoff team in
the national championship team they're
13 and 11 over the last two seasons so
just forget about this season you have
to combine last season two and so this
is not a championship team this is a
Holiday Bowl team that's a good team
what is your bar of success and you got
a new president and new people in charge
there I think you should go out and get
a championship coach that being said
that it's not a simple task at USC Pete
Carroll of everyone loves Pico he was a
third choice so we'll see um clay Helton
is an amazing human being a great coach
I just don't think he's the right coach
for this team yeah my wife was covering
USC yeah when she first started Paul
Hackett was a judge and then that went
sideways and Pete Carroll was like a
last minute afterthought he's got no
attachment to the school we can't we
can't go outside the the program and
then obviously we saw what happened
there is Urban Meyer do you think fans
would like to see just because of his
track record of success that you know if
I bring a man you're gonna be competing
and I know he has some stuff that has
happened in his past but I think there's
a lot of football fans they just want to
see that team competing again and I
don't know how you can bring clay Helton
back there are so many fans who just
want to move on and get a new coach so
that's the big name out there but rich
historically they have not gone that
big-name guy
arash thanks for coming in man have a
happy Thanksgiving I get a long drive
back dude just make sure you would you
mind going on ways to make sure you know
because sometimes if you make a right
instead of a left a lot forget it you're
just staring at taillights for at least
another hundred feet would you mind
doing that Amanat thank you good to see
you may 8th 442 all for rich your phone
calls and we check on the poll question
when we come back here in the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on
live or download the Rich Eisen show app